flavio wanted to estimate the mean age
of the faculty members at her large
university she took an SRS or simple
random sample of 20 of the approximately
700 faculty members and each faculty
member in the sample provided Flavio
with their age the data were skewed to
the right with a sample mean of thirty
eight point seven five she's considering
using her data to make a confidence
interval to estimate the mean age of
faculty members at her University which
conditions for constructing a T interval
have been met so pause this video and
see if you can answer this on your own
okay now let's try to answer this
together so there's seven hundred
faculty members over here she's trying
to estimate the population mean the mean
age she can't talk to all seven hundred
so she takes a sample a simple random
sample of 20 so the N is equal to 20
here from this 20 she calculates a
sample mean of 38 point seven five now
ideally she wants to construct a T
interval a confidence interval using the
T statistic and so that interval would
look something like this it would be the
sample mean plus or minus the critical
value times the sample standard
deviation divided by the square root of
N and we use a T statistic like this and
a T table and a t distribution when we
are trying to create confidence
intervals for means where we don't have
access to the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution but we can compute
the sample standard deviation and now in
order for this to hold true there's
three conditions just like what we saw
when we thought about Z intervals the
first is is that our sample is random
well they tell us that here that she
took a simple random sample of 20 and so
we know that we are meeting that
constraint and that's actually choice a
the data is a random sample from the
population of interest so we can circle
that in so the next condition is the
normal condition now the normal
condition when we're using when we're
doing a T interval is a little bit more
involved because we do need to
assume that the sampling distribution of
the sample means is roughly normal now
there's a couple of ways that we can get
there either our sample size is greater
than or equal to 30 the central limit
theorem tells us that then our sampling
distribution regardless of what the
distribution is in the population that
the sampling distribution actually would
then be approximately normal she didn't
meet that constraint right over here
here her sample size is only 20 so so
far this isn't looking good now that's
not the only way to meet the normal
condition another way to meet the normal
condition if we have a smaller sample
size smaller than 30 is 1 if the
original distribution of Ages is normal
so original distribution normal or even
if it's roughly symmetric around the
mean so approximately symmetric but if
you look at it this they tell us that it
has a right skew they say the data were
skewed to the right with the sample mean
of 38.7 5 so that tells us that the data
set that we're getting in our sample is
not symmetric and the original
distribution is unlikely to be normal
think about it it's not going to be
you're likely to have people who are you
could have faculty members who are 30
years older than this 68 and 3/4 but
you're very unlikely to have faculty
members who are 30 years younger than
this and that's actually what's causing
that skew to the right so this one does
not meet the normal condition we can't
feel good that our sampling distribution
of the sample means is going to be
normal so I'm not going to fill that one
in choice C individual observations can
be considered independent so there's two
ways to meet this constraint one is is
if we sample with replacement every
faculty member we look at after asking
him their age we say hey go back into
the pool and we might pick him again
until we get our sample of 20 it does
not look like she did that it doesn't
look like she sampled with replacement
and so even if you're sampling without
replacement the 10% rule says that look
as long as this is less than 10% or less
than or equal to 10% of the population
then we're
good and the 10% of this population is
70 70 is 10% of 700 and so this is
definitely less than or equal to 10% and
so it can be considered independent and
so we can actually meet that constraint
as well so the main issue where our T
interval might not be so good is that
our sampling distribution we can't feel
so confident that that is going to be
normal